Hi,
Dr Peterson,
I've been wanting to ask you this,
uh,
for a while now since I started watching
your lectures.
Um,
after I started reading a Nietzsche's
beyond good and evil,
I came upon a paragraph in his chapter
on scholars that really,
really bothered me and it's actually
bothers me to this day.
Uh,
he,
he talked about this kind of person,
like they were just a mirror,
like they stretched,
he said every part of their skin
basically to allow every new piece of
information that they took on and then
all they ever were was just an
instrument.
They were just a mirror reflecting what
they had learned,
never actually having generated anything
on their own.
And it's bothered me because I feel like
in a way sort of like,
it's,
it's impacted my identity a lot because
I don't know,
how are you supposed to create
something,
you know,
so.
Okay,
well that's okay that,
that's a really good question.
I mean,
nature is often clashed with the
existentialists right?
And so one of the tenants of existential
is there's two real tenants of
existentialism.
There's more,
but obviously we're over simplifying,
but one is that life is a problem.
It isn't because there's something wrong
with you.
It's that life is a problem,
and so that's often contrasted with the
Friday and view,
which is that if you have a problem,
it's because something went wrong during
your development.
The existentialist said,
no,
no.
It's like life is a problem.
Make no mistake about it,
and that the purpose of
the purpose of scholarship is in some
sense to solve that problem and so for
Nisha,
like he said,
all truths are bloody truth to me,
and what he meant by that was that if an
idea didn't incarnate itself in you and
transform your perceptions and your
actions,
then you were merely possessed by the
idea you.
You're merely a spokesperson for the
idea.
Or You could say that the idea possessed
you.
You're a puppet for the idea.
It's not you.
It's the idea is in you and it has you.
You haven't taken the idea and
incorporated with you and made it part
of your life,
and so there's a romanticism that's
associated with that,
right?
That's the passionate scholar.
The person for whom ideas are not
merely,
they're not merely,
what would you call abstracted
representations that can be tossed about
as if they're commodities.
They're,
they're,
they're more like,
they're more like personalities.
That might be another way of thinking
about it and so if you're,
if,
if those ideas are compelling,
then you don't like.
One thing I learned along time ago and I
think this is probably relevant.
I know when I was a kid I liked to argue
and I like to win arguments or,
or,
or lose them,
although I like winning them a lot
better,
but I didn't really mind so much what
the content of the argument was.
You know,
I,
I could engage in it like a sparring
match and it was in some sense to
establish dominance,
right?
To establish intellectual dominance.
I quit doing that when I was in my mid
twenties because I thought that that was
too shallow and approach to the ideas.
They,
they're not commodities of that sort.
They're there.
They have tendrils that reached down
into the living.
That's the right way to think about it.
And so nature's criticism of scholars
and he did this a lot,
was that they were bloodless.
No,
they didn't.
They were full of performative
contradictions.
That's another way of thinking about it.
They'd say one thing and do another
because their intellect was completely
dissociated from their,
from their actions.
And he,
he,
he thought that was a very bad idea.
And I think that that's a good
criticism.
I think it is a bad idea.
I also think it makes for an
extraordinarily boring lecturer,
you know,
because you can tell if you're listening
to someone,
whether the ideas that you're hearing
are merely being passed through the
person as if they're being memorized,
say,
or whether they're part of the dynamic
core of the person and if they're part
of the dynamic core of the person,
then they're almost always engaging in
gripping.
And so he wasn't a fan of bloodless
scholars.
And I think that's correct because one
of the things that I see,
it's not a good idea to have ideas
possess you unless you know what the
idea is that we're up to and lots of
people are possessed by ideas rather
than possessing them and that what that
means is they haven't taken the ideas
and integrated them into their own
being.
They haven't.
It's like an incarnation in a sense.
They have an incarnated the ideas in
embodied form and so they're incomplete.
You know,
Nisha also in thus spake Zarathustra.
When Xero booster comes down the
mountain,
he sees a bunch of people gathered
around a famous individual,
I think maybe a scholar but doesn't
really matter.
And when zero theaster goes and looks at
the personality,
season's a little tiny midget with a
gigantic ear.
And so he's a hyper specialist,
right?
And so he has a pretty impressive ear,
but he's only this big.
And that was niches,
imagistic commentary on the danger of
hyper specialization and also on the
danger of adulation for hyper
specialization.
And because he thought about it as a
kind of deformity now,
nature was a pretty harsh guy,
but um,
but he did address the issue of the
relationship between intellectual
knowledge and action because for Nicha,
those things are not to be separated in
some sense.
So yeah.
So maybe,
I don't know why,
maybe it bothered you,
like it's hard to say why it bothered
you.
It might have bothered you because it
sort of undermine the idea of scholar.
But the other possibility,
and this isn't an accusation because
obviously I don't know anything about
you,
but it might also be that it struck a
chord,
you know,
and that maybe you were doubtful or
questioning how tightly associated your
intellectual endeavor was with your
actual character and your practice.
So that's another possibility.
I mean,
that's a really good thing to think
about because generally speaking,
that integration is very much lacking.
People are a lot smarter and fluid with
their ideas that they are ethical and
consistent and characterized by
integrity.
So
thank you.